right so I'm going to talk today about
the Wolfram compiler so this is a new a
new compiler project for the Wolfram
language it's a long term project we've
been working on this for a while but
hopefully soon we'll be having some sort
of releases things things that people
can use it's going to be a replacement
for the old the old compile technology
it's a completely new implementation and
it's built in the in the Wolfram
language so let's just start off with a
sample so that the new idea is you
compile the basic level your compiling
functions so they're compiling functions
and we give type markup in a different
way with thing called typed so we say
you know interest in 264 and we get we
get the answer when we invoke it so the
flow of processing of the compiler goes
through a number of stages so we
generate an inner form of the wolfram
code we transform this wolfram code
applying various transformations macros
analyses that are convenient to do on
the tree-structured wolfram code and
then we generate an intermediate
representation we do type annotations we
expand function definitions we do more
transformations optimizations then we
generate instructions for a thing called
LLVM we optimize the LLVM code we
generate machine explore cute machine
executables and then we can start
executing now an alternative flow of the
thing is that the first steps are all
very similar but then in we go straight
from this war from intermediate code to
some alternative executable mechanism
maybe C++ or Java Script so not not
using
LLVM right so just quick rundown first
step we create this inert form of the
Wolfram Code so this is once once we've
got to this form of the Wolfram Code
it's it's not going to you know it's not
going to execute and we can do all sorts
of useful things with it as a as a
representation of a Wolfram expression
next stage we do is we take that and we
generate this intermediate
representation so again I'm not going to
give too many technical details of the
compiler but this is what's known as an
SSA a single static assignment
representation of the wulfing code and
and it might not look look like it but
this is actually has the form of a
lambda expression that's a technical
detail it's got type annotations and
we've got things like this that's
calling into a library of runtime a
runtime library so I've given talks at
previous conferences about the compiler
and I'm going to this is like the latest
updates moving hopefully soon to a
release so the biggest new feature that
we have here is we have an entirely new
representation of types and type
inferencing mechanism there's a new
runtime so now we're starting to do
actual coding and program generation we
have some new parallelism features we
have machine code and assembler
generation more streamlined and
optimized we integrate nicely with LLVM
optimization and we have some
integration with LLVM debugging
mechanisms so talk about the type system
for a little bit
especially since type system is very
mathy and at least some of you here are
interested in in
in mathematics time sister naturally
touches on a very interesting core part
of mathematics that's really some of the
things that are at the very core the
mathematics of of mathematics it's very
interesting so some of the benefits that
you get from a type system so you can
get verification of your program you can
know that the program won't in you know
in various you know you'll have
confidence that it won't reach a point
and then stop run out of ways to
progress it won't you know it won't sort
of halt
there are ways that it can halt but many
of the ways that might halt can be
detected at an early stage and when you
uncover problems at an early stage
they're quicker to fix a particular type
system that we have has a sort of what's
known as a polymorphic way of we're
working with it and that's useful
because it means a little bit of code
can go a long way so it's efficient type
system is a way of doing reasoning about
the code you get knowledge and ability
to do reasoning and that's pretty useful
because then you can start to do
optimizations that are specific to
particular types so for example the
simple operations like say addition
adding adding numbers together if you
have floating-point operations I Triple
E floating point operations machine
number floats then addition is not
associative so you have to preserve the
order if you want to get reproducible
answers you can't reorder the the way
that you do the additions and you might
want to do that because if you if you're
adding lots of numbers together you
might want to make some sort of binary
tree to reduce the number of operations
on the other hand if you're doing
operations over integers it's very quite
valid to go and reorder the the
operations you might find a faster way
of doing it
so that's benefit now the benefit of
type system is you can create code that
is reaching much closer to the machine
hardware if you know more about it you
can you can target exotic hardware or
even if you don't have exotic hardware
you can reach closer to the to the
actual code so there's there's a number
of benefits so the type framework that
we've put together is supports what's
known as static typing we run a type
typing pass code processing time we have
an inferencing mechanism and that's
that's very useful so in all their typed
languages you had to put type
annotations everywhere in your code and
using a type inferencing no algorithm we
minimize quite significantly the number
of annotations that that are needed I
said before it sports a parametric
polymorphism mechanisms a little bit of
code goes a long way another interesting
thing about the framework we've built is
it's actually independent of the
compiler you don't you you don't have
you know it's not part of the compiler
it's independent so the compiler uses it
but other things could use it as well so
now some of the things that are not it
doesn't support so we don't have any the
big thing that we don't support is any
notion of subtyping so there's no
object-oriented typing there's no
template mechanism and actually the
parametric polymorphous polymorphism is
a more modern alternative to object or
object oriented programming was very
popular 1020 years ago but it's now not
so not so fashionable and we don't
support things like C++ templates which
is familiar with my little brain is a
good thing actually so
right so some of the details it's based
on a it's a hindley-milner system with
modifications with extensions and I can
talk about what those those are so has
its origins in a typed lambda calculus
with various sort of extensions and
that's you might say well this is
Wolfram language how can you use
knowledge of of lambda calculus to you
know
wolf language isn't a strict lambda
thing and that's why the translation
into this you know intermediate form is
useful because that is is a form of of
lambda calculus so it fits with another
Wolfram project that's going on there I
think there's going to be a talk I'm for
doing that's closer to the mathematics
of type theory that's using types for
theorem proving now as I understand it
theorem proving is a harder they're both
aspects of type you know working with
with with type systems but in a sense
theorem proving is you start with the
type and then you have to find a program
that has that type whereas what we're
doing is much easier we start with the
program and then we infer the type if it
has one always say no it doesn't it's
not well typed in which case we we
reject it and as I said before it fits
with sort of mathematical logic which
which goes right to the core of
mathematics so in addition to these
sorts of things we have to support the
Wolfram language so it's not going to be
very useful if it's it's so restrictive
and a couple of these things are kind of
important so we have two support
functions that take any number of
arguments that take multiple arguments
more more than more than one argument or
more than a fixed number of arguments
and maybe even an arbitrary number of
arguments I mean we have to do that
and in a strict a stricter you know
types this or stricter languages they
very often support only one argument and
they use a form of currying so if you
have you know like plus of you know a
comma B what really that is is that's
like plus of a is returning a function
which adds to another you know an
another argument but we we can't do that
it would be too too restrictive and even
more complicated is the actual type
depends upon what what the arguments are
and we need a way of encoding this into
the type system so you might imagine say
like the part the part function so we
could say part of an integer that's
going to reduce make a reduction in the
sort of depth of the expression and then
you could say well there's two of them
that's going to lead to two two to two
orders of reduction in in the death but
here's another part where we give the
list structure so this actually doesn't
lead to a reduction of two stages it's
just the reduction of one so the actual
type of these are all different
different versions of the part function
and they have different types because of
the the output type is you know it's not
just a factor of the number of arguments
and we have to take care of this so so
we have a number of these are sort of
type expressions that we can support in
the in in in in in our system so we can
have an atomic type integer boolean we
support function types this is the way
we write function types so we have a
list these are the in this is the input
and the output is boolean
now let's get more exotic so here we
have a type this is called a handle and
this depends upon another type so this
is a like a handle we use these names of
sort of arbitrary but this particular
type we use it to hold something that
would be like a reference or a pointer
to something that we need to so this
handle is quite general but it needs one
one argument and that could be an
integer it could be a function it could
be something else so we have these
polymorphic types so here's a
polymorphic type so this is a type that
has this is like a function in in in in
in in tight space so this is the
argument is is V and this is any any
type and the actual thing is going to be
a function that takes takes that type
and returns the same thing so for
example this would be a good
implementation of a type not
implementation a type for an identity
function now these polymorphic types
become more useful when you put
predicates onto them so for example here
I'm putting a predicate I'm saying it's
a variable but this variable has to
satisfy a property and for these it's
it's a membership of a set so we say
there's a set called number and this
thing here has to be an element of the
number set and it's a function so this
would be suitable for say like some
unary math function like abs or or you
know unary minus or something like that
then the last thing we have is we have
types that depend upon terms so this is
a composition so we have like we call
this a number or this is how we
represent packed arrays but raw arrays
similar and so the base sort of quantity
that's in there is integer and we have a
two and so this would be this is the
number of indices this would be a matrix
if it was one it would be a vector if it
was three it would be you know some sort
of higher higher tensor it's not really
tensor in the physic sense but well
here's another example this is where
we're specifying the length of something
so this would be a type that represents
a vector of integers of length two and
this might be a matrix matrix of
integers it could be boolean Zoar it
could be functions a matrix of something
and it has two rows and five columns so
with these it's quite an expressive
language so we can start to write type
signatures so here for example is a this
is a function this would be suitable for
an append type function working on this
this vector thing so this is a vector of
something we haven't said what that
something is it could be integers or
billions or reals or functions or
whatever and other lengths and we
haven't said what its length is but the
output is going to be a vector of the
same base but now we've incremented the
the the length so this would be an
append function or here I've written a
type signature for a matrix multiplied
so we have a matrix it has right rows
and columns and another matrix rows and
columns so it's a bit like pattern
matching this these variables a little
bit like pattern pattern variables but
we say the you know the number of
columns has to match the number of rows
when we're getting then I sound right
and the output is going to be a matrix
of this this type here so it's quite
quite
sym succinct language and were able to
represent you know quite quite quite
useful properties in such a way types us
the names of types of strings that's
that's what we've done right right now
let's look a little bit at some
operation of this inferencing system so
after like restart my kernel I'm going
to keep an eye on the time now so this
is I'm now I'm not using the compiler
I'm just using the type system so I'm
going to initialize a type environment
this is like a built in type environment
it has a bunch of types of knowledge and
things and I'm going to do create a type
inferencing State for working with a
lambda with a sort of mini language and
I'm going to do some inferencing so what
I have here is I have a lambda a lambda
function this is a little bit like
function and it takes an argument and it
returns that same argument and I'm going
to apply it to an integer account the
constant one and the output is going to
be one so this is the essence of typed
lambda calculus you have terms so this
is a term you have abstractions
functions
that's the lambda function and then you
have application and when you look at a
book on lambda calculus this is this is
where it starts so we can do inferencing
on this or we can take the same thing
and apply it to a like a boolean and
that's we get boolean so that's purpose
that's all that's all good here's
another so we also have added a
mechanism for adding knowledge of
functions so here I'm applying something
that's a variable and it looks this up
in a mechanism
and it's supplying a thing called
identity and it's supplying to the to
true and the answer comes back that's
that's going to be a boolean and this is
the mechanism that we have so I'm
looking up the this this is all done
sort of internally in the inferencing
mechanism but I'm applying looking in
the type environment I'm looking up the
identity function and this is this is
the type so it's using one of these type
frawls and we can go lots deeper I mean
I'm don't really have to go in for this
but we've we've developed this lambda
mini language and we use this for
development and testing an understanding
of of the type framework and we can do
this independently of the compiler which
which which which which we found pretty
pretty useful now let's restart
everything's gonna restart again so now
I'm switching back and I'm actually
going to show a little bit how this type
framework is used in keeping all the
time and so now I'm going to generate
some wolfram intermediate representation
but I'm sort of turning down I'm sort of
halting the conversion process at a very
very early stage and so what we see here
we've got type we know what the types of
the arguments are they're they're
integers but here's there's a plus you
know it's you we don't know what we
don't know what type plus has and we
don't know what type the output is and
the same four times and we don't know
what what the result of this is going to
be so now we're gonna run an inference
thing we're going to do inferencing on
this and now everything has been we've
determined all of the types that we
might want to know so we know that the
function is taking two integer 64's and
returning an inch to 64
we know that the plus that's here is the
version of plus that works on to end
returns an integer and the same four
times so now we've added quite a lot of
knowledge to the to the system so next
stage would be to then go and look up
implementations and maybe create them
they might be written polymorphically so
in which case they'd have to be
instantiated and we're going to look
those up so we run a function resolution
pass and it then goes and has created so
we've now got calls so this is now
specialized the plus to a specific class
that takes particular argument so it
adds sort of name mangling system maybe
we might use a c-plus all might ask is
why using C++ naming mangling and
probably we should accept the names are
so horrendous it's quite useful being
able to read read the things and then
these so now we've got these two
functions this is a call into the
runtime library which is called in a
particular way so we can track runtime
errors in the arithmetic that might be
necessary we might want to track those
so this is now some eight making more
progress we might also I haven't shown
this we could in we might decide to
inline these function definitions or not
there's lots lots of strategies and and
such like so and I'll just note
something about this inference err is
it's not just this is what's kind of
cool it doesn't just go forwards it sort
of goes backwards and sideways and if
there's enough knowledge it'll produce
the answer and if there isn't it won't
so here i'm i'm i'm creating a handle
this is like one of these reference
things and we know that the handle we
know that it it's a handle but we don't
know what sort of handle it is so we
have a variable here but notice i'm
storing in the handle the argument and i
know what the argument is it's an
integer 64 so now when I run the
inference ER it's it resolves all
these unknown variables it goes through
this process unifying things finding
substitutions and it's able to sort of
infer all the types so without a lot of
markup it's able to produce the correct
result so we've been developing and an
ontology name of type C ty that's that's
what that's we're working in the domain
the plus function that we have decided
to use is one that takes you know we're
working the domain of of in 64 that's
what it does
it's an error if you don't if you don't
like that and you want to be able to go
wider then you should be using a
different type which which will be
providing but this is that's not but if
the output doesn't fit into an in 64
your your you'll know that
okay let's I'd like to keep going if
that's okay we can talk you have an
ontology of names of types that we've
been working through these are the sorts
of names that were coming up with of
course these names are completely
arbitrary but we choose common
conventions you know sort of it etc now
so this is the sort of thing that huge
amounts of work goes into and most
people don't really you know it without
but it's super important to get this
right this is we need a library to drive
provide common arithmetic and utility
functions and we need to really
understand how they're working we need
them to be
this is totally eating your cake and
having it because we want them to be
super fast and very understandable in
how how
they work so this is a big a big
development effort that we have to build
this library it's it's being implemented
at a C++ template system it's shared
another nice thing it's shared between
the compiler and and the kernel so we
get you know we only have to write one
but a code which is useful and things
work in a common common sort of way
we're using latest compiler technologies
where we can track these errors and
things in in very efficient ways and
it's it would also be a standalone
library so if we had standalone compiled
applications would would work now so the
compiler and LLVM we use LLVM as a
back-end steven was showing this last
night so what is LLVM so the first thing
to remember about LLVM is it's not a VM
so right lots of people think oh it's a
VM like the Java VM or or Python that
you know whatever it's not LLVM is a
compiler infrastructure
it's like GCC or something you know
other compilers and it provides a large
collection of compiler tools for working
with different input languages and
output targets and what's really nice
about it is it's written I should I
often think LLVM if we were writing
something like it it would be the way
that we would write it it's written very
nicely as a set of reusable components
and it's very well set up for extension
and this might contrast it with GCC
which is a very respectable compiler
technology but I think it's probably
true that to do similar sorts of things
to what we're doing here with GCC would
be extremely hard but actually as I can
attest you can start get get to grips
with LLVM and look at the source code
and understand how it works it's if
you're interested in compile
that is it's quite you know it's it's
quite robust and easy to work with so
has this well-defined intermediate
representation which is kind of you know
isomorphic with the Wolfram intermediate
representation which is GCC has a
similar thing as well um LLVM is very
there's a lot of momentum a lot of work
behind it at the moment it's the basis
of the clang C C++ compiler and it's
backed by lots of companies and it's an
emerging there's more and more support
goes into LLVM I think if its origins at
the University of Illinois just just
down the road it's also tools that work
with LLVM debuggers transformers
profilers etc and it has all sorts of
things that people do with it you know
like integration with GPUs so but I'm
just going to stress this is just the
convenience
we're not specifically tied to LLVM and
I think we're starting to explore
developing alternative backends we might
want to compile into C++ or compile into
JavaScript and then we probably would
not be using LLVM we just go from our
intermediate representation right fine
now generating LLVM generator here's the
the output it's actually kind of the
same sort of thing this is a string
representation if there's a binary
representation which is called bit code
not Bitcoin bit code right so right so
LLVM provides a nice feature
that's called awk JIT so awk stands for
on request compilation and I've read the
story that the developer of orc jet
thought it it'll be really cool to write
something called awk
so what can I write so that he so he
started with the name and then he
thought that the project to fit it to
but it's turned into this great useful
useful thing the nice thing about this
this on request compilation mechanism is
that it's a way of producing an
executable so it produces like a machine
code representation but it lays it out
in memory in the in your process and you
can start executing it and the benefit
of that is you don't need to go through
like like a linker chain so so an
alternative which which which might be
useful for other ways but not for how we
want to use it in the first instance
would be to create an object file and
then link that into a library or an
executable so we're able to avoid that
and we get a simpler simpler torture you
know a simpler chain and it's kind of
useful so with this I are you can do
this some benefits of LLVM so so here
what I can do I've we have some
functions so this is one that takes
takes the IR that we produced and it's
written a machine code file so if we go
and look at the you know I'm using the
UNIX file command and it says this is a
Mac object Wow so this is something that
I could link into a library or or create
an executable and actually Connor is
going to be showing some examples of
this got to give a good over time right
so you could also do things sleep Steven
show this I can convert this into
assembly so this is assembly that would
be suitable for my Mac and in fact the
object file I produced is just a binary
representation of this this assembly or
you know this is a good thing about LLVM
it's very cross-platform so you know on
one machine I can produce output it'll
run on a different type of machine and
that's often useful because here I
generated Linux arm so Linux arm is
often used in like him
you know smaller like raspberry pies
those are useful machines but they can
be slow so running a big tool chain is
can be a pain but I could do all the
compilation on a nice fast you know
Intel machine and then target this this
other machine so that's that's that's
what we have there now how are you doing
last last another thing that we can do
benefit of LLVM is we can run
optimizations so we're still tuning some
of these things may be machine learning
might be a useful way of tuning the
optimizations so here we've we've
parameterised the optimization set you
know sequence that clang uses so in
clang you would do - oh three so here
we're doing clang optimization level
three and it it runs that but this is
actually what you're this is what clang
is actually doing when you say and in
fact I think you can give these as
arguments to clang if you want to but
it's quite and the sequence of what you
actually choose to run this or it's not
not totally trivial right fine so
parallelism so it's one of the things
that we wanted to I was always very
excited with the compiler to try to
leverage multi-core modern processors so
in a warfare engine there are already as
a lot of parallelism there's it's this
is multi-core not the parallel toolkit
where you fork off kernels which is also
a useful form of parallelism but this is
a sort of lighter weight form of
parallelism so it's quite hard to do
this in the Wolfram language itself the
old compiler has some ways of doing this
but it's a little bit awkward and it was
a key goal of the compiler project to be
able to do this so the way that you
would try not to be this is kind of
schematic one what
would be to do this is you would set up
some sort of work unit and you'd give it
say two four threads you'd have them
running and then you'd wait till they
all completed there is lots of details
and strategies and improvements that you
can do with this but a key requirement
for this is to have a compiler that can
run with nested functions so here I've
got an outer function but it has two
inner functions so this outer function
so you've got one function where you've
got a function here and this this inner
function takes a function as an argument
and it applies that to the argument this
is obviously contrived and the other
thing here is this is the inner function
so we pass one function in is the other
and so we can work with this and we get
a little print statement that's another
new thing and you compile is to be able
to work with strings and do printing and
stuff like that quite useful just to get
some sort of feedback and this is quite
quite quite useful and just you might
get a bit more of an idea when you look
at the intermediate code so here's the
this is the main function so we have one
function here and this is this function
here has the type signature first
argument itself is a function so it's a
takes a function that does integer to
integer and an integer and it returns an
integer and then these are the other the
other functions and there's the class
function so since we can work with this
we can pass functions around as
first-class objects that's needed to be
able to write you know sort of parallel
time operations so now we can we can
utilize this so it slight defect at the
moment of the compiler is the
compilation step is takes is a little
bit slow and so I'm starting this up but
basically what I've written is I've
written
a parallel map and it takes a function
and it takes an argument and the
argument is a packed array and it takes
a count and the count is going to be the
number of threads that that's used in
the operation so this is calling threw
in some after some work it calls a
thread a thread layer that's that's
written in in in in our runtime and we
can invoke this so here I'm running it
so I'm giving it you know packed array
10 million elements I'm saying use one
thread but now I'm doing it and I'm
saying use use for threats so now this
particular function adding one I could
do that with lists of all with a list of
all operation and that would also be
quite fast and that would also be be be
be be done in in in parallel but what
because because our runtime library
supports that but when our runtime
library doesn't won't let you do is for
example if you had something that had a
a branch in it so here I've got some
rather silly function so if the sign of
this thing is greater than 0 does this
big blob otherwise it's it's this and
there might be more work that we could
do to you know optimize this so now I'm
going to run this and so if we use sort
of 8 threads we're getting some nice
some some nice speed ups and we could
turn on this LLVM optimization and and
get good even faster but this is this is
quite a good way of leveraging the
multi-core nature of the computer now I
mean how quick pause and we can look at
some other work that Connor
you
yep okay can everyone hear me yep okay
login so so we're building this compiler
and you know we're generating
executables you know native machine code
and there are tools for debugging these
programs that already exist and we like
to be able to use them sorry what
ah yes okay yeah I can do that and make
it bigger too is that good read that
okay I'm just gonna run my knit code so
we've got sort of show the changes so if
you're building a program in debug mode
we'll load the program sort of Tom
showed this created an inert form of the
expression compile it wider and we can
see that the intermediate representation
that we generate has these primitive
function debug values added so these
appear in the program wherever a symbol
in the source programs value has changed
or maybe it's you know a function
declaration or module declaration
wherever new variables introduced or an
old variable has had its value changed
and these get translated down into sort
of similar primitives in the LLVM ir
which basically do the same thing except
these have you know there's more
information here that's hidden as
properties on these objects but that's
fully exposed in the LVM ir so you have
these value statements and they have the
variable they refer to so the actual
value where it appears in the IRA and
what is the value and a second argument
ignore this third argument is a
reference to a metadata node which
actually represents you know this was
this source variable in the program you
know if you have
in the program that we just compiled
there was an x and y variable and that
node is visible down here it's a DI
local variable it says you know we have
this variable n and the source it
appears in a certain place and you know
as this name so when we create something
we might actually want to debug that's
too simple we're gonna be something bit
more complicated so now we have just a
simple program it counts up
does it sum again a bit contrived but
works to show this off compile this
again probably don't need to look at
this again but similar it's just more
complicated function it's got some
branches in it so they're multiple basic
blocks but not much different than what
I just talked about so now I'm going to
create so this creates a shared library
that we use library link then to load
back in and again this is you know a
user using this when we released this
would not have to do this but so we got
to do now so I'll get the process ID and
now I'm going to use a program called LL
DB which is sort of LLVM s own debugger
similar to gdb a bit more modern though
so we'll run this and I will attach to
the kernel process 6:9 and there's this
first little thing that we can continue
past and then I will actually run this
function that I've just compiled we can
see we hit the breakpoint that appeared
and we can look at the local variables
oops
so I'm printing the local variables I
can see they appear there now this is
the most assembly I could step through
this for a while but it would get
tedious after a while we haven't even
made it to the oops to the first they're
optimized out there haven't even made it
to the first spot you know that the
second iteration loop so this is kind of
useless but that's ok because if we do
it's a different way instead of loading
the expert from notebook we can load it
from a file after turning on the
debugger so this sort of activates part
of the kernel and causes it to annotate
the act
expression with line information which
we can make use of in our compiler to
generate executables that keep that
information so here's the inert form of
the expression or inert form of the our
source expression it's the same program
from before just from a file on my
desktop and we can sort of inspect this
and we can see this you know breakpoint
that appears in the third line does
indeed you know we remember that appears
in the third line and we can create more
LVM ir from this go through the steps we
can see each of these statements in the
LLVM ir are annotated with a debug tag
so this sort of says this statement in
the program in the compiled program
appeared in this place in the source
program so we can actually look at these
say okay we're the conditioned loop you
know the value for whatever 0 is I think
that's probably the counter appeared on
line where is annotated with debug node
metadata 17 we can go find that and it's
the location the source program line for
column information currently not
accurate so now get to the final the fun
step actually create again as we did
before a shared library load this
function from that library should make
sure this is still correct yep obviously
and run this function and we see here in
ll DB Wolfram language source code that
we can step through inspect the local
variables just like we would you know in
a C program or anything else exactly the
same and I should do that check this out
some initial values step through maybe
at the end of the loop we can see that
our counter has changed or our sum has
changed go up to the next iteration of
the loop same thing have to go after the
sum of course yeah now some has changed
so we can see this is working
oops that's not very helpful yeah and we
could continue steps through this a few
times get to the end of the loop again
just updating the values exact
it would you know you might see and if
you're dug in debugging an equivalency
program get to the end finished step
through and that's our driver program
but we don't need to look at that
so yeah that's that's basically it we've
attached a little from kernel process
and we can look at compiled code in the
same way would compile to code so what
do you do playing - gee any of you write
the write C code
you
right so that was that's a benefit of
working with LLVM using you know we
don't have to write that it comes for
free with quite a lot of work from
copper actually to add those annotations
but still that's that's that's that's
that's pretty nice so now I just want to
finally end in the last few minutes look
a little bit at what coding in this new
compiler system looks like so in the old
compiler you just got one function and
that was very limited but now we have a
bit more we have more flexibility you
can add types and things you can add
more function definitions we're not in
version one going to be supporting down
values and in fact the hold down value
mechanism pattern matching can benefit
from this technology but we are being
focused trying to get this finish to get
a version the first release and we're
focusing on function compilation but
what you can do is you can add add code
to a type environment and you can do do
some interesting things so here I'm I'm
getting a like the default type
environment and I'm going to add a
definition to it so I'm adding a
definition of a vagi CD there's there's
a story while I was interested in G CDs
but this is this is a if you go and look
at Wikipedia this is the implementation
of a GCD so I've added that I think I
yep to the type environment so now I can
invoke this from if I do a compile using
the same type environment it'll find
that definition and it'll it'll use it
so now I'm calling it these things gonna
get a lot faster and I can I can call
this so yep that's great looks like the
GCD of 30 and 12 six sounds feasible so
more optimizations in this function here
it's making
of course but actually many of them are
what's known as tail-recursive so
they're just kind of at the end just
before the thing exits and that would be
a quite feasible thing for us to write
an optimization pass to detect these
recursive calls and then add all we need
to do is add an animated data to that
call instruction saying this is this is
tell recursive and then LLVM will will
will optimize it so that's that's kind
of a nice thing right here is a faster
version of the binary GCD you don't have
to look at this wikipedia has a nice
description of this and now I'm going to
invoke this and basically instead of
doing divisions it's doing bit shifting
as a faster way of doing this GCD
normally does in you know quotient
remainder type division and then it sort
of switches them around and what you're
left with is the GCD but this is a
faster way of doing this and this this
one here avoids recursion and it gets
the same same answers now I'm going to
recompile both of those seven time round
it's built up this cache which need to
build and I've turned on LLVM
optimizations and now I'm going to
invoke this with kind of a bit of a
worst-case situation so these are two
too large numbers really quite large
numbers that are relatively prime so
it's going to have to do an awful lot of
work to figure out actually they're
relatively prime so the GCD is one and
I'm comparing the recursive one the non
recursive one and the built-in GCD which
actually uses the same the same
algorithm but this is the where actually
this is the built-in GCD but the one we
just wrote is faster and let me stress
it people kind off
come along and say oh I know you know
I've written this faster way of doing
something and if you take some more
limited domain of course it's easy to
make something that's that's faster you
might write a function there just knows
that these two inputs has you know the
answers one you know but but but this
isn't a limited domain this is taking
the same so that's quite good too right
essentially top level code that beats
beats the sort of built-in thing now
another thing we can do if I can find my
mouse is now what happens if we want GCD
computations but I don't want it for I
don't want it for integer 64 I want it
for unsigned integer 60 you know image
processing very important to have so do
we have to like copy everything rewrite
you know copy and paste no we don't we
make one new implementation but we write
it polymorphically so now the type
signature which was integer 64 we write
it as with a type for all and we say
there's type variable so the the
argument has to be an in you know a set
of signed or unsigned integers and it
has these so that's so one
implementation will then go and work in
in this whole range of ways so that's
that's kind of kind of useful now I
think that's probably yeah so I'm coming
to the end of the talk running out of
time in a few questions
it's a few more talks coming up at the
conference later this afternoon
Romans giving a talk on parallelism
that's using some new technology in our
private clouds seems like a good use of
private clouds to you know make a
parallel computation mark has the other
thing with parallel implementations
often you need new algorithms and Mark
has a description of some interesting
ways of doing solving ordinary
differential equations with with peril
techniques that's something that we're
quite interested in trying to code code
into this there's a talk on Friday that
is kind of the theorem proving and the
type theory aspects related to the type
system that I was talking about and then
also on Friday Abdul is giving another
talk on the compiler with some other
interesting ways of using it and some of
the possibilities and advances that we
might should should be having so just
summarize I've given an outline of the
new wolfram compiler it has lots of
possibilities but the one thing people
always ask me is when when is it gonna
be out so we're working extremely hard
to focus down on a version one which I
think we're getting closer to two coming
out hopefully and maybe not in the next
major release I would hope strongly that
there'll be some some you know that will
be having something I think that's quite
feasible and it'll have features similar
features to the things I've been showing
today so multi-core parallelism a wider
range of integer and floats and we need
those in other parts of the system so so
like you know a lot of these machine
learning net networks that we've been
being seen some of those they they work
on you know they need to work not with
you know double precision floating point
numbers they work with single precision
floating point numbers so that's also
useful in image processing so we want to
be able to build libraries and tools and
things for people to work like that and
I'd also like them to be able to get
top-level Wolfram language code and have
it run blindingly fast and
benefit from that so the has some string
support that's that's that's quite
useful much easier ways to extend the
system so calling functions adding
recursion things like that and and some
you know sort of nice nice nice nice
fast execution of things so I think I'll
wrap up for now I could probably take a
couple of questions or something but
yeah thanks thanks very much thank you
[Applause]